[MUSIC PLAYING]
All right.
Here we go.
So before my life
here at Google,
I used to be a creative
director at Pogo.
And in the process, I
created a lot of games.
And most of them,
they were pretty good.
But there were a
few flops as well.
Now, the hit games, those
are great because those
are the ones I feature very
prominently on my LinkedIn
profile.
But the flops were
the valuable ones,
because those are the ones
where I learned everything.
And I started to notice
patterns with some
of mistakes I was making.
And as I discovered,
these were mistakes that
were not just specific to me.
Lots of people were making them
in lots of different games.
And so I wanted to share
three of them with you today.
So first mistake I often
see, one of the most common,
is kitchen-sinking your design.
This is a term I use when
you have a game where
you're basically throwing
everything but the kitchen sink
at it.
And generally, this
is because you're not
confident with the
core game design,
and you are trying to compensate
by covering it up with junk.
The most common
symptom is this-- hey,
let's add more power
ups in our game.
If you keep throwing more and
more power ups at your game,
that's a good sign you are
probably kitchen-sinking it.
I suppose if you're
more of the academic,
theoretical-game-theory-type
of person,
it manifests itself
this way-- hey,
we should add some more
risk-reward mechanics,
because those are
always good, right?
Yeah.
They're good.
But you know how many you
should have for any given
system in your game at most?
One.
Right?
Any more than that, and
your audience gets confused.
So what do we do if we're
kitchen-sinking our game?
We need to fix our core.
You are adding all this crap
because deep down you are not
confident in your core design.
It needs to be fun on its own.
So take away all your power
ups, all your bonus levels,
and just play your game.
Are you having fun yet?
No?
Then make it fun first.
Once you've done that,
then, yes, it's OK go ahead
and your power ups back in.
They're great.
My advice here is
concentrate on power ups that
change the way the
user plays and not just
the same but better.
Think of the super
leaf in Mario,
or the power pellet
in "Pac-Man,"
or the gravity gun
in "Half-Life."
All very, very nice power ups.
Oh, and by the way, if you
find that your game isn't
any fun without a
particular power up
or a bonus level, that's OK.
Just take that and make that
your base game experience.
And then kind of build up
your end-game conditions
and scoring and everything
else from there.
We did a couple times at Pogo.
It worked out.
Second big mistake I often
see-- holding onto good ideas
longer than you should.
So sometimes we find this great
hook, this new twist, whatever,
and we're so proud of
ourselves because it's
the most clever idea ever.
The problem is that it is
ruining everything else.
Let's say, for
instance, we've got
a really clever way of adding
a time limit to our level.
And so it's really
neat and innovative,
but the problem is our
end-game isn't very good yet,
our scoring needs
work, and the power ups
are also kind of boring.
But every solution
we come up with,
we put in the reject
pile, because it doesn't
fit our time-limit system.
Or to put it another
way, let's say we're
trying to make a sandwich.
I've got some great mayonnaise.
But then we've also got say some
peanut butter, and some jelly,
and maybe a banana, none of
which we put on our sandwich
because none of it
really goes with mayo.
But what ends up happening
is instead of getting
to eat a delicious
PB&J, you're at home
eating mayonnaise out of a
jar because you couldn't find
anything that went with it.
So the solution here
is hold the mayo.
I'm sure it's great mayonnaise
and/or time-limit system.
But it's preventing
you from getting
your sandwich or game made.
It's not doing you any good.
And so this happens all
the time in game design.
You are going to have a ton
of ideas both good and bad.
I think any run-of-the-mill
game designer can kill the bad
ideas.
But a good game
designer is the one
who can kill the good ideas
that don't serve the core
or perhaps are preventing
better ideas from coming along.
As the saying goes, sometimes
you have to kill your darlings.
So moving on to
the third mistake
I often see, rejecting
bad suggestions
just because they are bad.
So here is the issue.
Play testers are going to
find fault with your game.
But, you know, they're probably
your friends or your fans
and so they want to be nice.
So instead of telling you,
hey, your climbing system
is kind of poopy, they're
going to say, hey,
have you thought about maybe
adding a grappling hook gun?
Well, here's what happens.
You know your game way better
than this other person does.
And so your mind
immediately latches on
to the five perfectly
legitimate reasons
why a grappling hook
is the worst idea ever,
and it will ruin your game.
And, you know, we're
game designers.
Sometimes we're a
little defensive.
Sometimes we're a little petty.
And maybe there's
some of that going on.
And we tell this person who
dared criticize our game why
their idea is so terrible
and it's never going to work.
And the thing is, we
are absolutely right.
But here is the problem.
Of course their
suggestion is bad.
They've been playing your
game for all of 10 minutes.
They don't know any of the
underlying systems that
are going on underneath.
They're just trying to help.
And so if you say, well,
grappling hook, that's
a dumb idea, and
you move on, then
you have missed a
golden opportunity
to notice that you're climbing
mechanic isn't any good
and needs to be
fixed, because no one
else is going to tell you this.
So don't shoot them down,
silence those voices that
are telling you-- again,
totally legitimately--
why their suggestion is bad.
Instead, stop and
consider why they
are giving you that
suggestion in the first place.
What are they trying
to fix for you?
Or, you know, you
could just ask them?
That works, too.
So, in summary, one, don't
kitchen-sink your design.
Fix your core.
Two, don't hold onto a good
idea just because it's good.
Sometimes you have
to hold the mayo.
Three, don't reject a bad
idea just because it's bad.
Look at what problem your users
are trying to solve for you.
Incidentally, the great thing
about all these problems
is that the best defense
is simply being aware
of the fact that they
exist in the first place
so that you can
identify and call them
out the next time they happen
to you, which they will.
So look at that.
You've all become better
game designers simply
by showing up and listening
to this presentation.
And with that, I am out of time.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]